comment Jacques vous y êtes pris vous
pour entrer dans les prisons et
qu'est-ce que ça vous a fait les
premières fois où vous avez repassé la
porte de la prison mais pour y aller
pour voir d'autres détenus
chaque le rouge vous qui avez passé
presque 18 ans en prison est-ce que la
prison peut être comme le dit ce jeune
homme un moment de reconstruction un
moment où l'on reprend pied
la prison devrait être
on oublie bien souvent que le principal
rôle d'administes d'administration
pénitentiaire c'est non pas de garder
les gens mais de les préparer à leur
insertion alors Jacques Le Rouge vous
aussi vous avez un parcours d'exception
mis un parcours quand même assez assez
différents puisque vous êtes aujourd'hui
l'un des trois condamnés à mort donc à
être en liberté et vivant
j'avoue vous avez 53 ans vous êtes marié
vous avez deux enfants vous avez été
condamné à mort très jeune une peine de
mort enfin pendant quatre mois à
laquelle vous avez échappé de justesse
ensuite ou cette peine a été donc
transformée en condamnation à perpétuité
et ensuite en 82 ça a été remplacé par
une peine de 20 ans
oui à quoi date des cours ce qu'il faut
dire aussi et je disais parcours
d'exception parce que aujourd'hui vous
vous occupez vous de en prison vous
entrez dans les prisons vous y retourner
pour pour mettre sur pied des formations
professionnelles ensuite vous vous
occupez d'une certaine manière du
service après-vente puisque vous occupez
de l'insertion professionnelle et tout
cela aussi grâce en partie à Monsieur ou
complètement grâce à vous monsieur
Grosjean Jean-Yves Grosjean puisque vous
avez ouvert votre porte à Jacques qui
cherchait du travail c'est aussi une
rencontre donc ça qui vous a permis de
reprendre pied
[Musique]
là aujourd'hui vous avez eu une vie très
jeune enfant une vie de galère et très
vite vous avez été jeune délinquant oui
c'est-à-dire que bon mais mes parents se
sont séparés après la guerre
donc à ma naissance pratiquement j'ai
été élevé par ma grand-mère qui était
une brave fermière et que m'a donné une
radio merci quelques valeurs de base
quand même aussi et puis j'ai regagné je
dirais le foyer maternel où il y avait
mes deux frères qui étaient là et en
fait j'ai été élevé par mon beau-père
qui est en fait mon véritable père
puisque le père s'est passé lui qui qui
fait l'enfant c'est celui qui l'élève
et puis
après j'ai été condamné à la maison de
correction alors là je vais vous faire
voir aussi incroyable que ça puisse
paraître
je confirme que c'est authentique
d'ailleurs plus les choses sont
incroyables elles sont authentiques en
fait voilà c'est un moulin à café
électrique qui date de 1957 et j'ai été
condamné à la maison de correction
jusqu'à 21 ans pour voler ce moulin à
café électrique parce que je voulais
démonter pour prendre le moteur pour
faire articuler mon jeu de mécano donc
voilà le début de l'histoire le voilà
c'est l'objet du délit débordage toute
votre vie tout à fait et
c'est à quel âge vous avez fait ce vol
14 ans 14 ans et lorsque vous passez
devant un juge des enfants qui vous dit
monsieur vous êtes condamné jusqu'à
majorité bon dieu merci aujourd'hui
c'est plus du tout comme ça heureusement
mais c'est à cause de ça que finalement
j'ai grandi dans les maisons de
correction où j'ai
oui j'ai trouvé ma famille c'est dans
les maisons de correction que ma famille
a grandi tous ceux que j'ai connu dans
notre correction je les ai tous
retrouvés en prison soit clair vous
voyez où ils en sortait où ils allaient
y rentrer parce que de toute façon
c'était l'aboutissement classique énorme
de la maison de correction ce que vous
dites c'est que c'est la maison de
correction qui vous a amené
à devenir un véritable délinquant oui la
maison de correction elle a eu quelque
chose de magnifique celle qu'elle m'a
transformé
[Musique]
éternel même encore aujourd'hui je ne
rentrerai jamais dans le système
elle m'a appris à connaître
[Musique]
à mes amis mes amis qui étaient avec moi
un peu perdu
vous êtes sortis vous voulez vous
arrêter trop d'émotions dans ces maisons
de correction qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce
qu'on vous apprenez à cette époque
Jacques
on découvrait je pense que
le seul souvenir que j'en garde je
dirais c'est les vis nocturnes des
éducateurs enfin ceux qui étaient
chargés de nous éduquer et puis qui
venaient à sauver leur fantasmexuel dans
les dortoirs voilà ce que c'était le nom
de correction
s tout à l'heure en vous rappelant
donc vous êtes retrouvés à 21 ans dans
la rue seul sans rien de 18 ans
et là la rue devant vous pas grand chose
là j'ai découvert ma famille la rue
alors vous vous avez commis différents
cambriolages vol de voiture
[Musique]
parce que dans ma tête
lorsque j'avais une voiture dans les
mains j'avais l'impression d'exister de
venir comme monsieur tout le monde
d'avoir un véhicule donc ça me
revalorisait en fait je faisais ça je
voulais une voiture bien évidemment
comme je t'ai couillon je me faisais
arrêter et j'ai fait comme ça 7 8
aller-retour pour des peines allant de
deux mois trois mois six mois 18 mois
donc des allers-retours vous avez 25 ans
là pareil à nouveau vol et là ça tourne
mal et là ça tourne très bien j'ai
carrément franchi le pas d'un
délinquance sans aucune transition c'est
à dire que tu voles de voiture je suis
passé carrément à l'attaque de banque
quoi mais malheureusement pendant la
suite ça c'est très mal déroulé puisque
on a été réfugié dans une résidence un
jeudi soir et puis les propriétaires
sont arrivés vers 22h et puis dans les
dans les dans les chafoués il y a un
coup de feu qui est parti le seul de
toute ma carrière de délinquant
d'ailleurs un trou et la personne est
morte de bactéridienne sectionné quoi
la suite de ça que vous avez donc on
vous avez condamnation à mort oui vous
avez toujours dit que c'était
un accident
et encore bon je ne sais même pas si
j'étais si j'ai tiré parce que l'arme
expertisait a été déclaré partir
accidentellement quatre fois sur cinq au
choc ce qui fait que personne n'est
incapable de savoir si je me tirais je
pense avoir tiré donc moi je suis encore
plus plus honnête moi je pense quoi mais
je sais ce que je sais c'est le jeune je
n'ai jamais surtout vous le tuer
quelqu'un ça c'est une certitude vous
vous êtes resté pendant quatre mois
presque 5 mois 5 mois voilà
attendre je crois chaque jour que cette
peine soit peut-être mise à exécution
oui bah j'ai vécu effectivement
pour moi qui ai tué en quelques secondes
croyez-moi la société ma guillotinée
moralement psychiquement pendant quatre
mois tous les matins de 5 heures
un moment donné vous étiez prêt à mourir
la nuit
plus ça va plus
vous vous appréhendez 5 heures du matin
5h du matin c'est l'heure de la
guillotine c'est-à-dire que tout bruit
suspect à cette heure-là en détention
déclenche chez vous
comme si vous êtes déjà guillotiné quoi
et c'est à tel point que même
aujourd'hui donc plus de 20 ans après je
vis bien quand je quitte ma maison à 5h
du matin pour aller bosser
on rend les comptes ah oui ça ressemble
à quoi une cellule de condamné à mort
parce que c'est ce sont des cellules qui
sont vraiment
faites pour les condamnés à quand
j'étais
elle existe encore toujours mais j'ai
pas eu le courage d'aller la revoir
d'ailleurs mais moi quand je suis arrivé
à la transférer d'Evreux à la prison de
Rouen
il y avait plus la cellule qu'on a la
mort servait de débarras
d'où là on aurait pu faire un jeu de
mots effectivement c'est là qu'on se
débarrasse effectivement mais ils ont
été obligé de refaire une cellule de
repeint d'une cellule donc on a la mort
de refaire ce sont deux cellules côte à
côte dont le mur mitoyen est percé d'une
lucarne de façon que le surveillant qui
est dans l'autre cellule puisse vous
voir en permanence 24 heures un
surveillant qui est à côté de vous 24
heures sur 24 je vais vous raconter
quelques exemples lorsque je voulais
prendre ma douche
je sortais donc avec les entraves et les
chaînes on m'enfermé avec deux
surveillants dans la douche on m'a
enlevait les chaînes je me déshabillais
le haut on me remettait les chaînes on
m'a lever les entraves je me
déshabillais du bas et on me remettait
les entraves donc je prenais ma douche
entraver enchaîné comme si j'allais
disparaître par le par l'évacuation des
eaux c'est à tel point un jour j'ai fait
une allergie c'était le surveillant
enchaîné comme ça qui me qui me
tamponnait partout et plein de
situations comme ça mais heureusement
qu'elles existaient à ces situations là
parce que vous étiez obligé d'en rire
vous avez réagi quand vous avez su que
cette peine parce qu'il y a eu vice de
forme il faut dire que la condamnation a
été cassée pour vivre de forme donc au
bout de 5 mois a été commué en donc en
pas été commu et je suis repassé aux
assises
à la mort et que pendant dans les cinq
mois ou que vous êtes vous en avez enfin
vous avez entendu qu'il y en a quatre
qui ont été au ciné
qu'est-ce que voulez-vous qui vous
arrive de plus rien
rien du tout le reste c'est de la
rigolade
vous avez tout de suite Jacques décidé
de vous prendre en main dans la prison
de faire des études d'aménager votre
temps je suis sortie
un univers que je connaissais beaucoup
mieux et c'est là que j'ai décidé de
d'assumer mon destin qu'est-ce que vous
avez suivi vous comme études et
qu'est-ce que vous avez fait comme
formation dans toutes ces années en
attendant d'être condamné j'ai passé un
souvenir d'étude j'ai passé un PEPC
puisque à l'époque ça s'appelait comme
ça
j'ai continué et pour la petite histoire
un des surveillants qui me gardaient à
qui j'ai appris l'algèbre etc et
aujourd'hui directeur de prison
voyez c'est
comme quoi et puis bon ensuite j'ai été
transféré à Clermont puisque c'était là
où tous les les durs les caïdes les
évadés en puissance aboutissaient claire
vous le cimetière des lieux j'ai passé
un paquet mathématiques à Clairvaux pour
la première fois dans l'histoire de
Clairvaux ensuite j'ai attaqué un deux
grands générique et je me suis amusé en
licence de philo de philo de psy voilà
mais là j'ai pas pu terminer parce que
je ne pouvais pas sortir pour terminer
mes études quoi parce que étant toujours
qu'on a la perpétuité à un moment donné
on peut plus aller plus loin je crois
qu'il y a quelqu'un qui a beaucoup
compté
je crois aux camarade
Toul nous sommes allés le voir et il
parle de pour l'écoute je croyais voir
un homme complètement abattu par dix
années de tension par Jésus après six
mois de cellules de condamné à mort en
réalité j'ai rencontré un homme qui
n'était pas du tout cassé un homme qui
voulait vivre un homme qui était battant
et
un homme surtout qui m'a appris beaucoup
de choses parce qu'il connaissait très
bien la prison le système pénitentiaire
et
il m'a appris toutes les ficelles je
l'ai dit de l'homme en prison pour
survivre il m'a donné son manuscrit
qu'il avait écrit pendant ces six mois
où les pensées de condamné à mort
et
à ce moment-là je l'ai lu et j'ai
découvert ce qu'il avait fait
évidemment c'était
un petit peu bizarre son histoire
mais j'ai mieux compris ce qu'il était
et surtout j'ai pu apprécier ce qui
était c'est un homme qui a toujours
voulu forcer le destin
c'est un homme qui un homme du défi
aussi bien dans le mal
par rapport à sa délaquence passée que
dans le bien actuel
et pendant le temps de prison je pense
qu'il a voulu redonner à ceux qui la
rencontrer un petit peu de
responsabilité parce que on ne peut
vraiment survivre que dans la
responsabilité quand on est en prison je
crois qu'il a fait une revanche sur
lui-même une espèce de défi
je suis capable de montrer que si
j'étais pendant des années en prison je
suis capable de vivre maintenant
vous êtes devenus croyant et tout parce
que vous dites mon ami le meunier mon
camarade mon camarade
c'est un ami mais c'est un hommelier
d'autant plus efficace quand 18 ans de
prison il m'a jamais parlé une seule
fois du bon Dieu
et c'est ça en quoi que c'est un
domaineier extraordinaire mais c'était
le seul lien que vous ayez avec
l'extérieur
et oui parce que j'ai jamais je n'ai
jamais voulu qu'on vienne me voir en
prison
il y a rien de plus déstabilisant
lorsque vous avez une longue peine à
faire d'avoir des parloirs pourquoi
parce que vous les attendez donc quand
vous les attendez ça devient énervant
quand ils sont là ils sont tellement
rapides vous revenez vous avez le blues
lorsque vous avez lorsque vous savez que
vous avez 15 ans ou 20 ans de prison à
faire en prison vous devez vous
installer et vivre en prison alors en 82
Jacques votre condamnation à perpétuité
a été commuée donc en 20 ans
à faire à dater du jour de la
commutation quand vous êtes sorti c'est
en quelle année
ce que j'ai souhaité lorsque j'ai fait
une demande de libération conditionnelle
c'est bien évidemment c'est comme mettre
pas la porte comme ça un jour au
lendemain donc j'ai voulu avoir un sas
de décompression donc j'ai sollicité
trois mois de semis liberté en fait je
suis sorti au bout de 17 ans pour aller
à l'enterrement de mon beau-père
alors du jour au lendemain mon camarade
Meunier est venu me chercher il m'a mis
à la gare à Nancy et je me suis dit il a
fallu que je me dépatouille tout seul on
est de l'argent mais l'argent je n'avais
plus aucune notion de l'argent je me
rappelle quand je suis arrivé à la gare
les portes automatiques et je vous dis
pas le bon en arrière que j'ai fait pour
quand c'est ouvert devant moi on a bon
le voir à la télé tous ces trucs là avec
lorsque vous voulez vivez directement
c'est plus du tout ça à ce moment là
faut pas se poser la question
voilà quand je suis sorti je me suis dit
je n'ai jamais fait de prison ça n'a
jamais existé et on repart mais c'est
possible bah oui mais j'ai quand même
très très mal vécu ça quand même parce
que je ne comprenais pas
vous ne compreniez pas quoi je ne
comprenez pas que mon beau-père s'en
allait alors que moi j'allais sortir
la personne qui subit était
celui qui a pris ma mère après la guerre
qui a élevé tous les trois il y a qui on
n'a jamais su dire merci
c'était le plus difficile de pas avoir
pu lui parler lui dire ce mot là
c'est comme ça ça a été violent mais
est-ce que ça vous a propulsé d'une
certaine manière comme j'ai résisté à sa
mode sympa de la mort j'ai résisté aussi
à cette retrouvaille de la liberté mais
quand je suis arrivé à la gare
j'ai fait à peu près je crois 12 km à
pied tout seul sur la plage pour aller
de la gare à chez moi parce que j'avais
besoin de décompresser tout ça quoi de
me préparer à cette affrontement là mais
avec le recul je dirais
c'était bien parce que ça m'a permis de
retrouver tous les miens et que jamais
personne
fait allusion à quoi que ce soit comment
ça s'est passé les premiers mois pour
vous parce qu'on n'avait rien j'imagine
pas d'argent donc des diplômes en poche
les premiers mois c'est la semis liberté
donc le premier mois s'est fait pour
dire bonjour aux oiseaux quand vous
quittez la semaine liberté pour
retrouver le soleil les branches les
odeurs c'est fait pour réapprendre à
essayer de revivre normalement de pas
faire des bons quand il y a des voitures
qui passent etc imaginez que moi j'étais
resté ODS donc la technologie avait
quand même progressé mais deuxièmement
c'est fait pour trouver du travail vous
écrivez sans l'aide personne ne vous
répond parce que tout le monde s'en fout
si c'est la vérité et ça vous attendiez
à cela
je pensais quand même d'avoir compensé
avec mes diplômes une partie d'une de
l'handicap et l'argent j'en avais mais
dans l'absurdité du système qui est dur
toujours actuel ça n'a toujours pas
changé depuis 10 ans
votre argent vous ne pouvez la toucher
que lorsque vous êtes libérable
mes libertés vous n'êtes pas libéré et
l'argent je l'avais parce que j'ai
toujours travaillé pendant 17 ans de
prison dans la journée j'allais aux
ateliers etc et le week-end
parce que je me croyais super riche avec
30000 francs quoi alors là j'ai rien
compris là
d'économies en 17 ans sur 17 ans de
travail c'est et là acculé comme j'étais
à ce point là je dis c'est pas possible
et ben là j'ai tenté le coup de poker je
me suis dit bon bah la presse a bien
vécu sur toutes mes affaires elle va me
renvoyer l'ascenseur aujourd'hui donc
j'étais j'ai contacté la presse le calme
le journal laisse républicain qu'est-ce
que vous avez dit à la presse à ce
moment-là
est allé sur la semaine et en synthèse
j'interpellait la société en disant
est-ce que c'est peut-être pas pu
intelligent que je trouve du boulot que
je retourne au trou et c'est à ce
moment-là je crois Jean-Mi le Grosjean
que vous avez
[Musique]
entendu si vous avez entendu
l'appel de Jacques Le Rouge était 85
vous vous êtes PDG d'une d'une
entreprise de formation professionnelle
et vous faites aussi du conseil en
entreprise donc à Nancy
pourquoi tout de suite vous avez
contacté Jacques vous avez été j'imagine
ému toucher vous avez eu envie de tout
de suite de lui rendre service c'est
vrai qu'il a il a marqué fort puisque la
solution est un très bon journal
régional avec des grandes surfaces de
pages
aujourd'hui je me suis dit voilà un
garçon qui doit être très intelligent
pour avoir fait cette démarche là depuis
plusieurs années je développais dans les
actifs j'ai tenté de développer dans les
activités une formation
pouvant être proposée dans les milieux
pénitenciers et je ne parvenais pas ni
un faire ouvrir les portes ni on
travaille dans quelques prisons mais
vraiment très peu or la formation
professionnelle si elle est bien faite
elle doit être dispensée par des gens
qui ont une expérience professionnelle
réelle
alors j'ai fait une proposition au juge
d'application des peines de Nancy j'ai
mis voilà ben moi je suis prêt à
rencontrer celui qui a fait les articles
là je suis prêt à lui proposer un poste
dans la mesure où après avoir passé les
tests d'entrée dans la société il
satisfait mais c'est là que les emmerdes
ont commencé si je fais l'expérience
parce que une reconversion comme
celle-là en fait c'est pas très facile
aujourd'hui elle serait peut-être plus
facile disons après mais il y a 10 ans
parce que quand on vous entende un
sentiment que c'est assez simple pour
moi c'était même pas une insertion
d'ailleurs c'était une entrée Jacques
peut le dire je me suis toujours forcé
de ne jamais le considérer comme
autrement qu'un collaborateur lambda et
je crois que là-dessus il y a même fallu
se battre parce que lui il n'entrait pas
dans la foule du collaborateur lambda
parce qu'il avait du mal à sortir de de
faire sa nu hein c'était vraiment pas
facile vous ressentiez comment cette
difficulté de la part de Jacques à
s'insérer justement il se sentait
redevable je souhaite aussi un exemple
facile un je vous demande d'aller
chercher ma fille à l'école au tout
début et je lui donne mes clés et ils ne
prenait pas mes clés de voiture il me
dit mais vous rendez compte de ce que
vous faites moi je comprenais même pas
parce que vraiment j'étais à sanglier de
penser ça il me dit mais vous me donnez
vos clés moi je vais prendre votre
bagnole et je me sauve vous me l'envoyez
plus surtout la voiture c'était déclic
je rentrais à 20h le soir dans mon
bureau et puis j'entends taper dans le
couloir comme ça écoute marteau je vais
voir c'était mon japonais qui était en
train de d'installer des des lambris sur
les sur les murs d'un couloir mais je
dis mais qu'est-ce que vous faites là
vous savez très bien que je ne fais pas
les heures supplémentaires donc vous
allez les inscrire sur un cahier et vous
les récupérez ah mais pas question tu me
dis vous présenter je dois tellement que
je fais bien vous faire ça gratos alors
là j'ai du coup là je me suis un peu
fâché je n'ai surtout pas qu'il y ait
des rapports comme ça entre vous et moi
sinon vous retournez d'où venez parce
que vous faussez tous bon je peux en
citer un bon nombre comme ça il l'était
mais c'était une forme de générosité de
reconnaissance et j'en voulais surtout
pas par rapport à un Japonais ensuite
les autres collaborateurs je souris
parce que vous l'appelez Jacqueminet
vous faites deux fois
on sent la relation chaleureuse c'est
très important parce que par rapport de
la manière qu'il va m'appeler il est
content ou pas content
de dire c'est ce qui est important c'est
que
la difficulté est venue surtout des des
parents des stagiaires que j'avais en
charge parce que bon la presse c'était
bien mais ça a déclenché je dirais notre
rencontre et mon embauche mais imaginez
la tête des parents des jeunes qui je
faisais des cours qu'on apprenant que
leurs enfants avaient comme professeur
un ancien condamné à mort je ne sais pas
combien de coups de téléphone monsieur
Grosjean a dû avoir je ne sais pas
combien de remarques désobligeantes
monsieur Grosjean a dû assumer et ça a
duré comme ça pendant quelques années
bien sûr je le savais mais je sais que
entre autres n'auriez pas été PDG de
cette entreprise vous auriez pu le
garder
mon patron il aurait fallu que
j'obtienne l'autorisation d'un patron
comment Jacques vous y êtes pris vous
pour entrer dans les prisons et
qu'est-ce que ça vous a fait les
premières fois où vous avez repassé la
porte de la prison mais pour y aller
pour voir d'autres détenus écouter
c'est sûr que je regardais derrière moi
chaque fois les portes qui se
refermaient et je me disais bon j'espère
qu'avant se rouvrir dans l'autre sens
j'ai un copain qui est chef éducateur
dans une prison qui m'a fait a trouvé
l'interpellation juste
j’écritais si j'ai critiqué le système
pendant 17 ans de l'intérieur six mois
de l'extérieur je n'essaye pas de
l'améliorer je perds le droit de
critiquer
la critique c'est facile
est-ce que l'administration
pénitentiaire par ailleurs vous avez vu
venir d'un bon œil illustration
pénitentiaire ne va pas vu venir du tout
comme ça
parce que
j'imagine que c'est très difficile ce
que vous avez fait juste devant il y a
rien de ficelle tout est officieux
aujourd'hui ça va être officiel c'est
vrai ça me poser des peut-être des
problèmes mais c'est pas grave j'espère
que non non
ça va déclencher le scandale ça va
déclencher un tas de choses et j'avais
besoin de 10 ans de recul j'avais besoin
de munitions quel scandale quel scandale
scandale de quoi les gens ont les gens
les gens bien bon sang vont dire mais
c'est comment ça se fait un ancien
taulard ancien condamné à mort qu'est-ce
que c'est que ça y retourne dans les
prisons c'est le monde à l'envers qui a
dit qu'il y a de quoi et moi je voudrais
j'en profite pour demander à Monsieur de
masse vous qui êtes donc d'un centre
pénitentiaire à Loos en Lille comment
vous vous réagissez justement au
témoignages de Jacques Lerouge nous
avons ici quelqu'un qui a eu à
s'expliquer sur des faits graves commis
il y a maintenant bien longtemps qui a
été condamné à purger une sanction très
lourde et qui a purgé cette sanction et
aujourd'hui je ne vois pas ou non de
quoi
nous tous le corps social on
continuerait de le désigner de le
montrer du doigt d'ailleurs dans les
deux sens en bien ou en mal le problème
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de moyens la
réinsertion ne préoccupe pas la société
ça faut le dire qu'est-ce qu'il faut
mettre en œuvre pour que ça fonctionne
à peu près 5 fois moins cher qu'un
détenu qui récidive la société aura
beaucoup progresser je dirais la
réinsertion c'est un sacerdoce si vous
n'avez pas galéré si vous ne l'avez pas
connu de l'intérieur
ça ne fonctionne pas très bien alors on
parlait de la famille du pôle familial
qui était aussi important pour se
restructurer vous parliez de votre
famille mais la vie amoureuse la vie
affective après quand on quand personne
ne vous attend
quand on sort il y a une chose à
laquelle personne ne vous prépare à la
sortie il y a quelque chose qui est
assez dramatique
en fait moi je suis rentré à 25 ans en
prison
et je suis ressorti à 25 ans dans ma
tête
donc personne ne vous prépare à combler
cette génération qui a disparu
les gens que je côtoie que j'affectionne
ont tous 20 ans de moins de mois
ma femme 23 ans de moins que moi
et vouloir vous l'avez rencontrer à
votre sortie
ce temps d'arrêt dont vous parliez ça
signifie qu'effectivement on reste dans
sa tête immature affectivement qui est
quelque chose qui ne sait pas combler
[Musique]
oui oui
au même titre que j'irai même
plus loin je dirais même
si vous me posez la question ce que vous
êtes inséré
je dirais je pense que tu partageras
aussi mon avis on ne sera jamais rien
serré
ça veut dire que vous resterez toujours
différents c'est ça que je travaille
toujours différent je ne peux jamais 10
ans après je ne peux pas dormir dans une
chambre vous la fenêtre n'est pas
ouverte et où les volets sont ouverts
essentiel pour vous de voir des enfants
parce que vous êtes un père évidemment
tardif vous avez des petits enfants qui
ont 5 6 ans
quoi tout à fait
je vais vous faire une confidence
je crois
que le premier je l'ai voulu pour me
protéger
un peu
pour mon interdire de revenir en prison
il y a vous allez me dire il y a
peut-être c'est de l'égoïsme quelque
part
je suis tellement heureux avec de toute
façon mais c'est vrai que je pense que
je le voulais pour pour moi pour me
protéger pour me donner des repères
toujours responsabilités
pour l'extérieur de la prise
et ça a marché quoi ça marchait j'ai
trouvé faut laisser le temps autant
c'est toujours la même chose j'ai trouvé
une femme qui m'a apporté ce dont
j'avais besoin la stabilité l'affection
vous savez je comment vous expliquez ça
peut-être que ma plus belle victoire moi
qui ai pris une vie action tellement
parce qu'il y a une pire que de tuer
quelqu'un même si on le veut pas
tuer quelqu'un c'est affreux quoi
je pense qu'au fond de moi avoir donné
la vie à deux personnes et peut-être
aussi
un moyen de compensation
pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne Ina
Mireille Dumas abonnez-vous et activez
la cloche
[Musique]